our perception is usually confined  within the limits that our ego dictates  we are raised to think individually and  not see logistically that process  seriously hinders our capacity to  understand and cooperate with fellow  humans and our ability to form mutually  beneficial connections suffers  dramatically empathy is the ability to  understand and share the feelings of  another it is a process that leads to a  complete re-engineering of a person's  worldview since it can offer them a  completely new perspective on life  cultivating empathy is the first step  into unweaving the mysterious  entanglements that encompasses our  social life